you could just explain to the people
listening
sort of who you are and a little bit
about your background
sure
I'm a former Barrister
in England there are two types of lawyer
solicitor or Barrister Barrister does
the work legal work uh mainly in the
courts
and represent clients in the courts
um it's a it's a profession divided
between
solicitors and barristers in this
country
and um I used to be a barrister but now
I'm working full time on other issues
and one of those issues is Satan is
ritual abuse which I have worked on for
the last 27 years how it started was
when a British MP Member of Parliament
approached me about a Satanist ritual
abuse
case that he had been approached about
and asked me to get involved because he
knew that I was involved in campaigning
for children's rights
uh and I've done a lot of work over the
last 27 years on children's rights
issues including child sex abuse but
also SRA
and
it started from there that was in
January 1993.
so more than 27 years now I've been
following this issue of SRA speaking out
on it campaigning on it
uh sometimes writing articles doing
interviews speaking at conferences
trying to get a word out because this is
a very hidden issue and this is what
makes it so
difficult to deal with sometimes is the
general Public's ignorance of the issue
or disinterest in the issue or sometimes
the knee-jerk reaction of skepticism
which makes it
difficult to get them to take action on
the issue
so explain what exactly is SRA
Satan is ritual abuse is a brutal form
of mistreatment that is inflicted on
children
are vulnerable adults
and it involves
psychological
physical and sexual abuse
and it is done in the context of
Satanist rituals
and it is normally
in most cases done not as a one-off
incident but as a repeated form of abuse
over a period of time usually a period
of years that the victim is subjected to
SRA
so it flicks huge damage on the
survivors
some of the people who are subjected to
SRA do not survive unfortunately
uh sometimes they are murdered as part
of the ritual uh usually in a
ritualistic way uh we call that ritual
sacrifice
and it is the Satanist
rituals and the Satanist beliefs
that Encompass this what I would call
atrocities against
children and vulnerable adults it's
sex abuse and torture
combined together
and it's repeated over and over
and it's held basically for the victims
who have to go through this
and when they come out at the other end
if they survive and they try and tell
their stories to others usually they are
victimized a second time by people
rubbishing what they are trying to
reveal and saying that can't be true or
you're telling lies or you're delusional
and I would refer to that as a secondary
form of abuse
so one thing that makes it so hard for
the public to accept is because it's so
awful it's unimaginable
horror
but it does exist I think throughout
human history we have many examples of
people thinking that oh well we've
already reached the depths of human
depravity can't get worse unfortunately
it does get worse so there was a time in
the UK for example not that long ago
when even child sex abuse was
disbelieved
because people found that too horrible
to accept
and just didn't want to to believe that
it was true and the victims of child sex
abuse who were trying to report it were
disbelieved and were scolded or worn not
to repeat their allegations again
and now we have the same kind of
disbelief
uh in many cases leveled as SRA
although I'm pleased to say that the
public interest in SRA and willingness
to seriously consider it as as a real
issue
is starting to shift in the right
direction
at least in the UK
I know you have a struggle in America as
well over this issue but I think one
advantage America has is that it's a
more open Society than the UK and it's
easier to talk openly about these
subjects over there than in the UK or
other parts of Europe
so what was it like or how did you
become aware of this for the very first
time
yeah so I was basically just saying like
who made you aware of it and
what was the situation
well I I had heard about this subject
before January 93 when I first started
working on it
uh and I had done some reading on the
subject so when I was asked to take on
this issue
I wasn't totally unaware of what SRA
consisted of
uh but in a way I was thrown in at a
deep end because I was asked to
meet a group of SRA survivors who were
being treated by a doctor
and all of them had
dissociative identity disorder did which
used to be known as multiple personality
disorder
so
I saw some adults for example in front
of me
uh shifting from their core adult
personality to a little child
personality
that
caused them to talk in a very different
voice act in a very different way
these
uh fragmentation of their core
personality into all these different
what we call Alters
alternative personalities is actually a
survival mechanism more than a disease
it's not a disease it's not a mental
illness it's
a survival mechanism that
victims of SRA especially children use
because what they're subjected to is so
horrible it's so horrific that mentally
a child cannot cope so what they do is
they fragment their mind
into other personalities
to cope with the the torture and the
abuse
and
they let that personality
bear the brunt of the suffering
and that enables the core personality to
remain safe and distance from it
so
in many of these cases you will find
child personalities
who exist
still at the time which they were
created so for example there may be a
case of an SRA Survivor who formed a
child personality in
1974 for example
when that person was being subjected to
SRA
and many years later that child
personality may come up
uh for example doing therapy
and still think in that child
personality
he or she will still think that it's
1974.
there's also sometimes uh what you call
a guardian personality
who is like the
bodyguard there to help protect the core
personality and that Guardian
personality can be very aggressive
and overly assertive
and if it's a female it might even take
the formal if it's a female core
personality it may the guardian might
even take the fall of a male
uh uh to
add to the aggressive nature of that
altar hmm uh so
it it's
a sad fact that about 80 percent
of people suffering from did
uh SRA survivors
that means the majority of the ID
suffers have the ID because since
childhood they were subjected to the
most horrible
abuse and torture by Satanist abusers
and
the end result the only way they could
mentally cope
and survive was through the
fragmentation of their core personality
into all these different personalities
[Laughter]